Under Jewish dietary laws (called kashrut),
eating pork in any form is strictly forbidden.
Jesus Christ was Jewish.
So why, on the anniversary of his resurrection,
do people traditionally serve ham?
You’ll often read it’s because ham is
supposedly a “Christian” meat, able to
be consumed by Christians but not certain
other prominent religious groups.
However, the real reason is simply because
it’s in season.
While modern food storage techniques and supermarkets
with efficient and worldwide supply chains
shield us from this fact somewhat, like fruits
and vegetables, different meats also have
seasons, and these depend on a variety of
factors including what the animals were eating
and when, where they were in their growth
cycle, and the availability (or lack) of refrigeration.
With pigs and cows, before refrigeration,
it simply made sense to slaughter them in
the fall.
Since it takes a fair amount of time to butcher
a beast as large as a hog or steer, the cold
temperatures helped keep the meat from going
bad before it could be properly prepared.
Another consideration was taste.
Shortly before slaughter in the fall, hogs
would be fed things like apples and acorns
that would greatly improve the flavor of the
meat they would ultimately provide.
As one specialty pork producer noted:
The tradition of acorn-fed pork goes back
millennia . . . . The oak nut was a diet staple
because the pigs roamed and rooted about for
acorns in the forests of Italy and Spain.
An acorn diet is today best known as what
makes the prized and pricey Jamón Ibérico
of Spain so succulent.
Butchered in the fall, most hams were prepared
and allowed to properly cure over the winter
to further develop their flavor.
This was a particularly important food source
this time of year in some parts of the world
where the rest of the stored meat would have
already been eaten, with little other meat
of any real quality available.
This was the case in North America where the
other traditional spring meat, lamb, was (and
still is) less in vogue, which is also why
eating ham on Easter in North America is much
more popular than other regions where Easter
is celebrated.
Conversely, in Europe, lamb is commonly served
at Easter, and the tradition actually traces
its origins to Jewish Passover feasts.
This is also certainly fitting for Easter,
with Jesus as the “lamb of God.”
Born shortly before the holiday, young lamb
may be slaughtered within 6 to 8 weeks, and
thus offer a fresh, as opposed to cured, option
for Easter protein when historically other
such protein sources were scarce at this time
of year.
Eggs are popular at Easter, at least in part
due to the fact that spring is the peak season
for their production.
As a result, eggs have been a part of spring
celebrations since long before Easter was
a thing; for example, decorated eggs have
been a part of the Iranian New Year, Nowruz,
(observed on the spring equinox) for millennia.
In addition to the refrigeration factor, like
pigs, cows are also thought to be tastier
when slaughtered in the fall.
This is due apparently to the fact that “the
frost has killed flies and sweetened the grass
[so the] cows are more comfortable.”
Among other things, cows slaughtered when
fatigued or in distress also negatively impacts
the shelf life of the meat.
Turkey is also tastiest in the fall because,
as the weather cools and the days shorten,
their hormone levels shift and they fatten
up.
On the other hand, since most chicken eggs
are laid in the spring, those that are allowed
to grow into chickens are traditionally slaughtered
in
the summer.